you were in The Joker how did that come
about I've done a lot of movies where
people are talking about a movie and I
go I'm in that movie and they go really
and then I go with the guy here the guy
at the thing you know the guy who said
the thing oh my God yeah that was you
yeah it was big part dude I wasn't
Almost Famous when I was a kid Almost Do
You Remember Almost Famous yes of course
yeah do you remember the angry promoter
lock the gates
you know what it is you transformed
yourself in that movie you're hardly
recognizable The Joker though that I
mean Todd Phillips I think was using a
few Comics he likes Comics but he gave
me the speaking part and it was a scene
with De Niro and it was it's actually uh
very funny because you know from doing
what you do and I talk to people too
eventually everyone becomes human so I
wasn't freaked out that it was really
right because you know when it comes
right down to it he's a guy just
standing over there doing whatever he
does but it is De Niro and I know that
I'm doing a scene with dinero and in
retrospect I started to think about how
many guys have done three Line scenes
with De Niro where it changed your
[__] life and he would be
hard-pressed to even remember you being
in the movie with him yeah that's all
right so but but here's what's so it's
so there's a walk and talk where we're
talking him and I and then there's a
scene that's in the Joker where we enter
the dressing room with the with Joaquin
for me to you know make sure he's on the
level so De Niro and I meet him we
talked for a minute but Todd says let's
just do it and I go all right I'm ready
he's like you ready I'm like yeah man
he's ready Bob yeah yeah so we're
walking and talking right so I'm like
I'm lit up I've been in the trailer for
four hours already and I'm like and I've
been running these three lines and I'm
like and I get out there and I'm just
and we hit like action and I just start
doing the lines and we do it and then
it's cut and then I go I go sit in my
chair and I watch De Niro sit in his
chair and then I see him wave Todd over
the director and Todd walks over the
Nero and he's nodding and then he and
then Todd walks over to me and he goes
uh you're coming in a little hot
oh now poor you but it was a good point
you know Todd said like look yeah you
know he's he's your boss so you you
wouldn't just be yelling at him in
casual conversation I'm like oh that's
right this isn't me no yelling in casual
conversation yeah one thing about De
Niro is that like you know everyone you
get your trailer over there was they
shot it in in New York and he has his
own traveling bunk her like it's this
giant it's like this movable apartment
that they Park a lot is this something
separate from what the movie studio gets
them like he's done so many films that
he has his own setup that he likes when
he does a movie and they do oh wow why
not why not why not why wouldn't he he's
De Niro and he's doing movies all the
time why not be comfortable why not
bring a pool with you you know did he
invite you into the uh to the trailer or
yeah you can't get in the end you thank
them no you just like all you're trying
to do like in the in that situation is
realize your place right you know you
don't want to be the annoying guy and
also you don't want to wander around
hoping you'll get eye contact with him
Amelia stalking him so you just kind of
you do you accept what you get and then
you sit down and do your [__] job and
you know I was there for like a week it
was interesting to watch this process
because these actors like the lesson I
learned from Jeff Daniels which I
haven't applied yet was you have to
learn how to use your face because all
film acting is face I never even thought
of that but it's true
but to watch De Niro like he's going
through stuff they're doing retakes and
like he's doing the Johnny Carson thing
for the Joker and I'm like you know
watching the whole process something
like this is a disaster he's really I
don't know if he's you know what's going
to happen with this and then you watch
the cut and you're like oh my God he
knew exactly what he was doing and he
looks perfect yeah De Niro